so late last night, early this morning.
As the violent Trump rioters were unable to
stop the counting of the electoral votes in
favor of Joe Biden being the next president
of the United States, Donald Trump threw Dan
Savino put out a statement.
That he is agreeing to leave office on January
20th.
Now, the the sick irony is when he lost in
early November, he was leaving office on January
20th.
And so I have kind of mixed feelings and mixed
reactions to this.
He finally is agreeing.
And yet it's irrelevant because he wasn't
going to be president anymore come noon Eastern
Time on January 20th.
And even in his statement, a quote, agreeing
to leave office, Donald Trump still repeats
the exact same inciting statements that led
to the violent Trump mob rioters yesterday
in Washington, D.C., Donald Trump saying,
wow, even though I totally disagree with the
outcome of the election and the facts bear
me out, that's a lie.
Nevertheless, there will be an orderly transition
on January 20th.
While this represents the end of the greatest
first term in presidential history, it's only
the beginning of our fight to make America
great again.
Imagine the delusion, imagine the delusion
Donald Trump lost the House for Republicans
on twenty eighteen in 2018, lost the Senate
for Republicans in 2020, and was made a one
term president amidst the most cartoonishly
farcical presidency we have ever seen.
We've never seen an actual a more authoritarian
president in the United States.
The modern era of politics was not even prepared.
We learned for something this absurd as even
many of the checks and balances were were
impotent in actually holding Trump accountable
for his ignoring those checks and balances.
And Trump says this was the best first term
of any president in history.
So it's delusional.
But the idea that only because Trump has agreed
this is going to be what takes place is also
just a laughing stock and making the United
States a laughing stock.
Trump was leaving one way or the other.
And the fact that it is so newsworthy that
he has now come out and said, I am agreeing
to an orderly transition of power is wild.
But then what's the most important thing?
The most important thing is that it's too
late.
It it's already not an orderly transition
of power.
And the fact that Trump will fly off to who
knows where on January 19th or January 20th
and golf and tweet if he's still even allowed
on Twitter, which is another story for later
today.
It's it's already not an orderly transition.
And I think that's what we have to understand.
You know, as I said, as we see some Republicans
now back away from Trump, they need to be
held accountable for the four years that they
defended him.
And in the same way that Donald Trump is now
backing away from resisting leaving office
and saying it will be an orderly transition,
the orderly has that ship has sailed.
Thousands of violent Trump assets stormed
the Capitol yesterday, breaking in and doing
all sorts of damage and even leading to the
death of one woman.
The ship has sailed on orderly.
And we can't now allow Trump to revise the
story by saying I'm going to leave in an orderly
fashion on January 20th.
That ship has sailed and we will talk a little
bit later about what the next several months
might look like.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show and follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman, The David Pakman Show at
David Pakman dot com.